twitter ceo jack dorsey donates 10
million dollars to the
boston university center for anti-racist
research
the sub the sub headline being the
social media giant ceo and co-founder
donated 10 million dollars to a boston
university research center
founded by ibram x kendi to combat
racism
um note this is not to combat racism
that's what candy wants you to think
that's what i don't know if jack
actually thinks that or not this is
basically amounts to a don't hurt me
payment from jack this is this is the
same
thing he needs to look woke so that so
that no one comes after twitter at some
level maybe he believes it at this point
it kind of doesn't matter but no
despite what the headline says this is
not to combat racism
what it is quite explicitly this new uh
institute at boston university is to
promote anti-racism
and as we talked about in episode 39 at
some length
um this is this is candy's rhetorical
trap he's created a binary which is a
false one in which he said
uh if you are not anti-racist and eye
candy get to define anti-racist then you
are racist everything that is not
anti-racist with my special definition
is racist and if you don't quite know
this
then you can mistake promoting
anti-racism for combating
racism right those those words those
things sound like they're the same thing
but but they're not
um and if you think they are as
presumably the authors of that
nbc article um believe
then you've fallen prey to this
rhetorical trap of candies
um so no once again you should be
opposed to racism obviously
uh and you should be opposed to
anti-racism which no was not in fact a
racist position
if you demand equality of outcome
then the person who profits most is the
person who invests
least so you you're basically setting up
a system
of freeloading that has no mechanism
for uh for policing and so
anyway the whole thing is so obviously
wrong
at such a simple level that nobody as
smart as jack dorsey could possibly
believe it but here's the here's the the
thing that i get from this dorsey bit
you point out this is a small amount of
money to him
it is a huge amount of money in an
academic context
and the vast majority of us right um and
the point though is it follows the exact
same pattern as what people are now
doing in much more mundane ways
a thousand times a day in every
institution in
uh the western world which is they are
solving their
own problem by making a gesture that is
then empowering the movement that then
comes after the next person so that they
will solve their own
problem and make a gesture so point is
look
i hate to say it right it's very easy
for those of us who don't have the kind
of money that jack dorsey does
to misunderstand what it would be like
to be in his shoes but in this case i
have to say
jack dorsey has enough money that he can
set himself up
for life he can insulate himself
completely from people showing up in his
neighborhood frankly he can move
wherever he wants in the world and be
safe by virtue of the kinds of things
that that kind of
resource will buy for him to
externalize harm on others for him to
empower a movement that is threatening
other people
by giving them a token amount of money
for him
and a huge sum for them he basically
just um hurt the rest of us by
uh creating a huge amount of
pseudo-legitimacy
so what i've called idea laundering an
institute at bu that's studying
anti-racism for the point of view
for the um purpose of generating policy
and writing narratives this is nonsense
and jack you just
threw a whole bunch of gasoline on that
fire presumably to solve your own
problem and
it it's uh it's absolutely unacceptable
i'm reminded of the famous um i want to
know how to pronounce his name martin
niemoller do you know how to pronounce
this guy's name
uh first they came for the socialists uh
quotations so let me just read it first
and then say what i hear
you saying as the modern update which is
just
horrifying so he wrote no i'll just read
it
but you can show it sure first they came
for the socialists and i did not
speak out because i was not a socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i did not speak out because i was
not a trade unionist
then they came for the jews and i did
not speak out because i was not a jew
then they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me
well the update uh that you were
suggesting that jack dors everyone from
jack dorsey to the people with
uh blm signs on their lawn who put it up
for fear that they would be
the people who would next see the lights
shined in their windows and be told to
get on the streets or else they aren't
part of the
right side here first they came for the
socialists and i
you know first they came to the
socialists and not only did i not speak
out
i explained to them why the socialists
were wrong
then they came for the trade unionists
and only didn't i not speak out but i
explained to them why the trade
unionists were wrong
then they came for the jews and i did
not speak out and i also explained to
them why the jews were wrong
then they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me it's not quite
right but there's some
horrifying update to his to his comment
from the holocaust
that people are engaging in now that is
even worse than just being silent
it is people actually offloading uh
the well-being of their neighbors and
the rest of society in order to protect
themselves for a very brief moment
yeah it's uh it's it's a increase
instead of your cowardice leaving others
vulnerable it's uh whatever the
active version of cowardice is while
you're where you're bending over
backwards to make life
easy for the people wielding the threat
you are in effect increasing the power
of that threat against
um the next people in line and i have to
say
um i i don't i see
an awful lot of cowardice at the very
top the people who can afford
best not to be cowards are in fact
most reliable in this respect that they
are the most likely
to bend over backwards and i i think
it's some perverse version
of because they have a huge amount
stored up they're calculating how much
they would lose rather than how safe
they actually are i mean if you can buy
your own security force yeah you know
you can put your house
you know on a hill and surround it with
guards and whatever else you're doing
you're in a much better position to say
the truth than those of us who
can't do that and some of us are
standing up so what the hell
i mean seriously if we can't depend on
somebody like jack dorsey
to say you know what that anti-racism
stuff you're selling
isn't anti-racism anti-racism if that
word is to mean anything would have to
be an end to racism it doesn't it's not
some
new racism that counters racism
until some you know utopian future point
well it's i mean it's related to the
truism that there's sort of a rolling
goal
that i don't remember if it's from
corporate america or from from tech
billionaire space but
people will say you know until until you
have your first million you imagine that
that will be enough and then you get
your first million and
uh they say oh well now i need five
million i i can't remember this sort of
emerges from the 80s maybe
um in in in corporate landscapes
where people you know become rich and
then realize that rich isn't what they
thought it was and they need more and
more and more and so
you don't you know maybe even jack
dorsey doesn't even feel like he's safe
right uh yeah
i'm not i'm i'm not justifying it i get
it you know
but on the other hand this is a this is
an international
emergency and if we can't depend on
the smart people of silicon valley to
figure out that western civilization is
coming apart at the seams
that they have played some role in
allowing that to happen and they have
some
obligation to the rest of us to put it
right that you know
we we are now you know at each other's
throats in the streets of
major american cities people are fleeing
those cities this is insane and
people like jack dorsey have an
obligation to stand up first not last